were so full podcast welcome back to the
what so full podcast with Felipe Esparza
and Rodrigo Torres yeah man how you
doing doc I don't know why but I sound
like Casey Kasem there you go going up
in the top notch this is Vin Scully it
was a beer Scully bro here sitting here
live with Dodger baseball and now the
upcoming shows I don't know what that
one we're gonna work on that one yeah
that's what I said I haven't been seen
it Vin Scully it cuz I gotta collect it
each time for Dodger baseball like a
little we've a long way yeah he's kind
of like a little weasel but a clear one
like it's time for dodging things yeah
man very guy with my career now sir old
school but it's when I got from New York
the one they used to do the arm this
weekend baseball Mel Allen with the name
yeah Mel Allen well I might as well they
were good boys yaffle before like you're
the good boys out to announce being like
ever [ __ ] up boylar there's matter lab
has to be distinct stuff but if you're a
boxing announcer having a raspy voice
sounds good too hey kid what a knockout
he's taking him to the 20th round it's
unlike Mick from a rocky dog come on
rocky it's got a Caleb no remember when
or McDonald had his own show real quick
yeah yeah I was an agency our social
photos and then he'll say something you
know like what time they saw Mickey
because I know he was doing a segment
about boxing right then he showed Mickey
that's right women weaken legs oh my god
that's why man if you have an orgy with
guys be careful man if you have our G
one day and three guys three girls when
I have sex with you and you're a good
fighter
Charizard so how to jump you're wired on
the way out this had an origin give me
to my egg results random to running a
threesome er one I'm down with a
threesome me too man
that's why I need already like seven
guys all right to die han girl three
guys one girl and I two chicks one
business I like I won't do that I know
like
my guys two girls three guys one girl no
guys are girls how about three guys one
girl me jerking off with my TV three
lesbian
nah man summer I was also called the
transit the transformation from a porn
stars I made a porn star who um telomers
Ella that's hand I know al la hey I met
on the airport she'll put on lotion when
I saw her leg but a perfect video she
was sitting in the middle seat I think
and I was sitting in the window and um
she was going to the haricot opening of
the Harry Potter writing in Universal
Studios Hollywood Florida
she likes magic of course so sweet
Lolita I was sitting like a fat goblin
next to her bro the dogs of war right
next to her and she'll put on lotion
then um she saw all those pictures I had
in my backpack and my bags will he like
stickers huh I say of course I do
then she showed me her stickers then she
was telling me that she does I'm porn
like porn just women okay
no guys did women get Cinemax porn no it
will be a hardcore porn I just there's
finger-banging and 15 hardcore [ __ ] like
that but I'm no I'm no male yet and she
was telling me that you started off you
know a lot of hot chicks started off
just lesbians you know just bunch of
lesbian teens a bunch of a bunch of them
and then you become so popular as a
lesbian that the money starts coming in
for you to see a penis now the rise of
Mia Khalifa over how it starts you know
and then you do that for a while woman
woman woman and I think this redefined
all of this throwback
shut up to desert the vine from Las
Vegas you the bbw yeah bbw big bad women
right yeah yeah big big women right big
woman honest a big black women so what
do you know what bbw stars were big
beautiful oh there you go all over them
take it up with me me w yeah no I'm just
trying to get there big beautiful women
yeah she told us all she started out
with just a man one one on one one
one and then this extra cash if you like
you know enough gang in an orgy but
nobody's touching you like there are two
girls a girl two girls going down
throwing down on a guy and he has sex
with the two of them but the one that
just got in she won't have sex with him
or touch him
but she's touching the other girls so
she's part of a threesome that extra
money
[ __ ] but she likes like in a guy game
so she took making a she's making her
career go long by just going a short way
started on scale yeah so now they are
for her Wow how about you go down in a
guy and every the first time ever she's
ever touched a man so now she's at that
level and then it goes to all right now
his intercourse with two guys you know
what I mean
right - guys - a rub complain after that
bro
double penetration bro or if she had sex
with five guys at one time then is
double penetration but one in ain't no
one in a vagina one that's one view then
one of her mouth she never negotiated
for that and then the last one the color
she ate the last one bros when you're
already like you you're like I'm
bangbros bro having sex in a bus was -
then your first black guy you could ask
for a lot of money a star is born a star
is born
but then by the time she has said with a
black guy she been in poor baby like two
years so that's what that she's done she
made all the money she can because after
you go like black dude what's next well
animals she piano man a guy off the
streets doesn't everywhere sit at that
point now she build her name her for
herself and she's headlining strip bars
you don't make a lot of money when fast
cash or let you say sometimes it on
Backpage right that's the last one or
the ultimate one is the other page on
Instagram but with a PayPal account you
only what it be selling Astor's I forgot
that the porn star chick that was on
Backpage dude Tara Chisholm
I think about it I'll mention it - oh
dude
alright forgot her name tell me
privately bro I think I have was a fool
upcoming shows August 18 Milwaukee
Wisconsin at Tata huama Tommy Potawatomi
casino the Northern Lights Theatre 192
shows August 24th through the 27th at
the Braille improv these tickets will go
fast so get them now September 7th
through the 9th Orlando improv I'm
coming back Orlando improv September
15th through the 17th at the San Jose
and problem
San Jose improv so these are Friday
starting Sunday shows huh my one-hour
special called translate this will be
premiered on HBO September 30 at 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time
check out the Philippa's WorldCom's last
tour for all show dates the rest of the
year
the only shows coming up yeah man uh
August 16th I'll be at levity live in
Oxnard for the Rico Mambo show so I'll
be there next week ladies and gentlemen
and every Wednesday night at Romano's in
Riverside at the concert Mount yeah man
that's all going on
yeah man whoo there last week last week
who do we have Annie McKnight doc I
didn't ignite man how did he still
around
oh yeah I didn't do anything to so sure
there was [ __ ] awesome and this week
or last week we had Rick Ramos all three
Harrogate Jerry
ah laughs well - he's acting man and do
my movie podcast you should come on what
do I melt Philippe the faces you make
movies I like yeah he's on a show love
don't love what love it's on Netflix
Bobby leaves on it who else getting
ready for a third season food acting
yeah a pepper tones on it two dogs
another little show yeah love watching
two other so are the choreo the one
where Pete Holmes crashing crashing I
haven't seen it yet it's good already
laying on it huh
oh yeah
how much of that is true but it's pretty
good that's what I heard you Judd Apatow
is doing whatever little that fool is
hardcore Christian ought to be a pastor
amen yeah man or hallelujah have the
Christian say um I've been watching that
show ray Donovan I thought it's cool I'm
on the third episode dawg
but watching a fresh version of that
sure we we we we watching that show are
now HBO insecure I feel good I listen to
a podcast with homegrown it I've been
watching that I had a meeting man with
diet for Funny or Die okay about a
television show I've been having to take
another meetings and trying to sell
another show broke another pilot money
that's what's up
you also been auditioning - yeah man I
auditioned for a show and funnier diet
and it's funny man how you could go
through the Automotion bro
if they know that it's reacting motions
you read to the producers today before
the audition and get to know the main
actor and the guy who are making sure I
get to know the vibe then you go
audition and none of the people in the
audition met the producer but I did
let's do don't get it maybe for later he
knows I remember I had the other
producer on the phone talking to me all
the way to the audition in a real
audition and I still didn't get it and
I've got show never here by the way I
blew the audition but imma know I'm a
better actor now bro it's not good you
get better with everything huh yeah man
I'm do it plus if I see a little bit of
lines I know I'm gonna get it oh yeah
there's so many lies on my OD in a
dialogue and this fool you been getting
more comfortable with them before
oh yeah no one do I go into two issues
like I don't give a [ __ ] you think
that's the attitude you're supposed to
have oh I go in there now like Morgan
Freeman like in the last part of
Shawshank Redemption a Totoro again
clean up for parole he goes do you feel
you been have you have been rib
rehabilitated rehabilitated what do you
mean do you feel like I felt bad for
what happened
what do you
not a day goes by I don't think about
what happens I want to reach out and
talk to that young man you see bangs
away the guy young man is long gone and
audience is old man so ya mad so he was
the way he came in I didn't give a [ __ ]
them worry about whether they're gonna
get paroled or nice been there a long
time I go to audition I don't know the
ones the roles you've gotten yeah cuz
you know what I'm not that I noticed
and was in my last audition for Brooklyn
nine-nine that um the in the lid the lid
egos I'm a big fan of your comedy right
away before I came in there so when we
were reading she made me do it like six
times
was I right because I guess if you had
to look if you have the look of the
opiate of the row they want they're
gonna help you no matter what if you're
a horrible actor or not til I came in
there man and there were some
professionals outside bro Leon so
professional bro fool to spend their
whole life acting fools they go to a
dishes all day and then go home and wait
on tables real actors so then realize I
went in there and that man you know my
knees been messed up right so [ __ ]
walking fool I just hope like I be like
the abandon of the audition for a little
small studio another big ass to you you
know I'd be nice again audition I'm like
up to the dissonance for like a studio
man where that's funny man I'm talking
about um about my lay we're gonna come
in but I guess at one leg I'm
complaining about two legs anyway so for
CBS is huge the one over there on Studio
City a lot on ramp 'red uh-huh so I went
over there for that audition man and man
was so full and that's who had to walk
over there limp you know that when I get
there they laid it was real cool shoes
I'm a fan of cool to it so I read the
lines without my glasses first when I
think I put my glasses on sure do
whatever you want so I put my glasses on
and then I read the lines
cuz she laughed then she should that the
second line we did it three times
perfect
then I went to the last part I did it
again and she laughed and she was I'm
gonna give this tape to the producers
who I never had that before
oh I've heard I will delete this and put
on the next guy you really heard ample
na ha ha ha ha ha damn that will hold
it's fun auger in our dishes where after
the audition I ripped the script or the
lines and turn and the ladyhood casting
people's trash can to show you how I
feel I saw when I say great job he's
gonna do a good job but this time I'm
really here great job at the audition so
I know it did good
oh yeah what a great job with legs good
cuz I'm [ __ ] outta here man I thought
dishing up I all the losers now I
remember when I would turn up I went to
an audition with big dog bro Kosmic I
really know I would never take a friend
to an audition go but I guess leaves you
need backup I guess so I'm there brought
in the lines were not for a gangster it
was not for a cholo but not for any of
anything bad but I'm there and there was
this whoa and that fool reading lines
bro like didn't he do his reading lines
out loud they got nothing to do with the
reading just to throw everybody off
whoa puto I match all away like that you
know dumb she added that ya know you're
doing a loud ok so they could follow
other actors could think that he really
for a cholo part oh I'll side waiting to
go in here oh damn did it work I
remember I was on an edition with
someone else and we know and then like I
threw up in my a bite in that box too
bro they called me so what I was gonna
say is like he took you to that audition
you know ok sir it's a JUnit anybody
else I can fit this role then you walk
in right there little ray of sunshine
marching RZA what's an audition for like
a 25 year old and their foot toe Flaco
with him bro
understated it fly coach other addition
to men they say now man we're looking
for like college professors here
that is too low said you're too old to
get to the Medtronic commercial I
thought double down you're saying 418 a
good 36 so what's up fool what's up doc
anyway bro a little bit I messed up my
back to myself and I messed up my ankle
about four months and for the help you
were like what happened we got fat but I
messed up my back what you do bro they
eat lay down oh hell naw dude flip did
in an attic man
whiskers cop bro so we're gonna miss a
day at work
workers cop break you gotta take
personnel yeah [ __ ] workers coming to be
called [ __ ] workers calamity dogs
part 2 that's it I was just suffering in
pain dog silently duck yeah man that's
it is that you haven't worked out for
four months dude I think I tore a
[ __ ] tendon in my ankle dog gotta get
that I'm waiting on my Obamacare dog but
can't get it now doc play stop it no I
got check stubs dog yeah okay you gotta
be super broke though so yeah okay man
yeah man I don't have a plan our I have
our arm do something Foofa I have enough
credit for to let enough health
insurance to last middle year okay oh
[ __ ] huh on sags Screen Actors Guild I
mean if I don't get another if I don't
get another row in the next year we're
gonna take it away but you have it for a
solid year that's what man I wouldn't be
so successful but I haven't done a TV
show that I could like see homies that I
don't know some people some big actors
do that to their old friends and they
put them in a little row in a movie or a
little television show just for two
episodes just to keep their insurance
that's what's up just to survive so
that's a run a danger if it will do that
right they do have a movie and put in
you know that audience movies would
always have comedians remember that
you've seen before but they haven't been
a shift in the last movie that doing so
Rodney will put them in the movies so
they can keep the health insurance
well that's badass oh dude [ __ ]
through a bone no but hey we got a
[ __ ] to mix over here
that water's too strong though that
story sorry man muttering that story
threw me off man I'm sorry
gg-get is drinking alcohol brown man
we're so full we've had a let it get
here on the podcast we've had a lot of
underground comedians we have reverie
here underground rappers we've had um
the people who are not so under grab
another on the ground kid frost baby
battle gene Baby Bash mellow man ace
even citric right citric webelo cafe
well below campaign I know sit right on
and right there we had cab g1 temper
down his manager lost a rental car and
he lost the hotel I said that's what
happens man when you have your homie mad
at you he's doing great - whoever one
day man will catch over Atlanta hell
yeah he's a Mexican Drake yeah man yeah
yeah he's good I think man that food is
a pie so that wraps hey and food here so
hit me up brother no we're [ __ ] one
bo-rail oh hell yeah
one brl Houston finally shout out to
Houston silence the only great carving
in Houston Texas I did laughs ooh we're
gonna win it we're go to Houston in
November hopefully we'll get held up who
offered through our pod cat did he has a
lot of stories last time we see it was
only hooked about with butter there at a
rumble that's the last time I seen him
he had his manager with the banana pollo
the brother I forgot his name he's
always with them on the roof then we saw
their manager at the show a little bro
in Victoria yeah dawg he showed up yeah
about everything with our full bro he
said with them took awhile via route
he'd to live with Gracie dog when he
first came out here is that when like
the time Julie was saying when like the
devil Gabriel sailing day bro next yeah
and then that's where before me and then
he won the Best comedian LA and then he
left
and he tried though yeah cuz I mean I
played last couple years he was towards
Mancino for a while but that foot said
man can't be out here man
Mexican comedian
I feel like during gangs we got
Riverside Community don't want to go to
LA to hang out Alec comedians we got no
we got a [ __ ] comedian from East LA
Boyle high South Gate with Covina de
fallar all tight I used to break down I
don't get allowance and you know
comedians [ __ ] patchy the gear he
can't see man peripheral yeah man what's
up with [ __ ] food man what's up with
tons of Anarchy bro
nothing food there over there [ __ ]
work on their first episode no I'm
waiting for the full episode yeah they
had to play more golf court more golf
tournament in [ __ ] voiceover yeah how
about citric right yeah yeah but he's
he's a cast member of time with the guy
who wrote it
I think yeah man right now they're
trying to gain money bro but shut up to
Momo Rodriguez and pitching in or
whatever or George Lopez special came
out funny buddy saw it out there but she
was live from DC he has said check the
entertainer and seduce him and some guy
named Ben baller yeah heard of him yeah
what'd he do he [ __ ] jewelry right
yeah he's like one of the dudes that
gives all the rappers their [ __ ] uh
about customs yeah why exactly my item
pieces one hundred Jesus Christ and she
is like you know I'm saying and we have
coming up also another comedian another
underground guy um but it's not really a
rapper anymore I'll get tattooed on his
face MC bond show broke MC poncho that
together those are the lowriders Noel
tattoo events he's clearly him Harbor
City harbor re yeah that's to what is it
MC buncha what's his name yes he punch
oh you know him right
no not really I've seen him from Harbor
area hey I got us I got a citric story
though on everything I was actually up
for the role that citric God on the
online Lopez no no no his big break on
there's an idiosyncrasy they saw me I
was one of the people that was going to
be in that role but I don't know how to
act or I didn't I want the ball here
though the fat enough or whatever it was
a for real dog sat there and reattach it
and then when citric got that part I was
like yeah that's the homie right there
and do all right there I just wanted fat
enough or big enough he told me like we
looking for a cholo type and I was you
know they just they just heard my name
of to mix so they called me out there
and then I just was inside enough
that's funny we're looking for gathered
here twice a side of Mexico
yeah they were wrong he saw me they're
like oh now you're not the one we're so
fool this introduce our guests you got
to mix got to man here you go the
wrapper of a lien and the first time
I've heard of here because you know you
know Compton man [ __ ] show up on
your timeline you know on Instagram by
solid fool and I said wait a minute man
I think I know this food from the hood
or somewhere you know because I should
do a lot of shows back in the days when
you're a child probably a dumb setup
attend up somehow graphics oh yeah yeah
we used to rock there all the time back
in the day I did a huge event that they
did at the original spot and see the
Chavez yeah that's the one out a gig
like yeah yeah well also before you go
to that though yeah outside gig I feel
like blue of them there and I know you
want to be must have been in one of the
show oh yeah yeah I supplanter where a
salon on the ground no Holly well yeah
you were there remember um Blues
experiment yeah talk about that so when
we got to facial I hear a rapper out of
our lay and believe it or not we crossed
paths on Instagram I'm using the
hospital and then I'm you know he always
bought the little rafts I started
following him I told him what's up fool
I don't know you but I hope you get
better
yes right right man actually hope I see
a guy man down and out he was in the
hospital you know people were showing
them love a lot of my family showing I'm
not a [ __ ] you I don't know this guy
show him love hope you're doing fine man
hope you doing you're doing great yeah
good man I got luck boy right yeah I am
super here man I [ __ ] in out of
nowhere huh
yeah well thousands of people [ __ ]
reached out to me because I had to get
my [ __ ] a right leg amputated under
the knee cuz I was a undiagnosed
diabetic man I'll slip into a [ __ ]
coma and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] coca-cola
dog all that [ __ ] Gatorade all that
[ __ ]
and yeah as soon as I went to the
hospital man thousands and thousands of
people literally thousands of people hit
me up and all that love helped me get
back in the game latias fans to the
heaven that bit yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean I was always like a underground
underground rapper out of LA and and you
know I always have support regardless
but yeah when that should happen like
it's crazy you know you go through some
crazy [ __ ] like that and you wake up and
there's like you know you got 6,000
messages and people all over the planet
reaching out and all my fans like
[ __ ] graffiti going to Venice Beach
and [ __ ] all over the world like you
know throwing me a bum gang [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you know all that positive [ __ ] help
me out man big-time so where did you
grow up actually I was born in east los
of born at USC medical and let my rangos
free air right there but regardless but
I really grew that's why I was born but
I really grew up in mid-city
on a labret on Washington and not that
nice little prostitution crack
neighborhood right there on the Brea and
Washington right there about the 10
freeway so that's what I grew up right
there most of my life common there's a
comedian who grew up in that area - I
think Alex Thomas some comedian you know
yeah right from that and he was telling
me that that blip real bust 9:00 to
12:00 a.m. 8:00 gang would be in that
buzzes a different gas clip Crips blood
Mexican and even Asian gangs because I
was one of those buses that ran yeah all
whoo 3:00 4:00 in the morning it still
ran like one of the few book if you want
to go to Hollywood that was a bus don't
sound about LaBrea to 12 men I said hey
I rocked that bus still two maybe last
year I just got another whip
so yeah I I rocked that bus man I'm
living on La Brea all my life back in
the 80s I was like a super prostitution
neighborhood like LaBrea like Redondo
that was like a little straw right
there's a little hole stroll so yeah I
grew up with this oh how is it will you
grew up in that area right there in the
90s in the 80s I grew up I grew up with
the man I would be like seven years old
playing baseball on the street and like
the hookers would come up and be like
let me show you how to hit baby and I
say like I be like a seven-year-old
we're like a hooker trying to teach me
out of bat and then my dad would be
coming home from work and it'd just be
driving by looking see looking at the
hookers and [ __ ] was kind of some tight
I'm a growing up man in the hood two men
will be playing baseball in first place
to play graph first player and second
playground but the best player to play
baseball was first one because other
cholos they drove their cars in the
field so they [ __ ] broke all the
slides and other monkey bars
oh we had an open field of play baseball
now before man you beat you'll be
standing in center field in front of a
slide dog patrol oh they [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up everything bro
yeah yeah yeah you always look at the
cholo that will [ __ ] everything up but
then you grow up
hell [ __ ] you should have to lay I'm
good I'm ready graffiti in his preschool
I remember man yeah I felt so bad man
we're throwing up the hood right there
in the neighborhood and um some little
girl pass by there running on our school
aha
and then forget that's all so badiy
that's a [ __ ] yeah me huh attracted some
word I'm not a teacher on every game
could be played on the street so every
game was interrupted every three minutes
because a car for like we're playing on
the street so it's like you'd be lucky
to get three four pitches and then
another car comes and then another car
comes and you know me so it was out
there I used to get a the hookers used
to pay pay me to a go get him a soda I'm
saying they'd be like go to the liquor
store homie knows me already now just or
get him a beer so I used to be like
seven years old going to get a beer and
just you know getting a dollar off the
hookers like ubereats on yeah during the
original the original all the one that
when the rat when the crack fool selling
crack they would punch a hole in the
wall they punch a hole in the wall right
and that's where they would put their
money on the crack so that they wouldn't
have it on the person when the cops
rolled on him
so whenever color every once in a while
when they get in trouble and busted we
would be waiting there like eight years
old waiting and as soon as the cops will
take the the dude out soon as they made
that right out of our street we would
all run and stick her hand in the hole
pull out crack or 50 bugs or whatever
like it was Calle little system and [ __ ]
like we were just waiting for fool to
get busted and as soon as they they were
there for running their [ __ ] it's
like a lottery you'd be like but what
you can do is some crack like we just go
that [ __ ] away like no they're too young
to [ __ ] with that so like what's holes
ever try to come back and look for your
ass after now they're you know they're
jammed up for hours you know means run
I added ice - hey man were playing
baseball man and then the old cholo show
up bro are you home run yeah yeah come
on homie over man swing for the family
ball faster so I come out my homie soft
easy melody no through the ball man the
foot hit it hard for fire bro Luther
Barbara ah comes with a [ __ ] roof
game over done what about a new ball all
right ma'am oniy when I get when I turn
20 it's cool better not be on pcp I'll
break a battle birthday so yeah I grew
up like that man right there a mid-city
man and [ __ ] dude I love the author but
I was born in each loaf I'm sayin I got
mad love for four useless and [ __ ] so
when you like when you start like loving
loving um hip hop and job right off the
top man like uh you know elementary
school [ __ ] Sugar Hill Gang another
you know here pop and Run DMC and all
that like Slick Rick all that like Oh
East Coast [ __ ] Katy you know I'm saying
like listening to Katy I just think you
know listening to Katy just sit there on
the controller and [ __ ] listening the
KDAY and I would take a out of shitty
escape recorder and I would like put the
tape recorder to the speaker and try to
make my own mixtapes and [ __ ] like that
you know all my dad my dad plays music
my dad plays keyboards and guitar so I
was always looking at him and I was just
a lovely with hip-hop you know that was
my [ __ ] you know that gangster [ __ ] and
you know all more into the East Coast
[ __ ] like I was getting into that East
Coast [ __ ] and yeah man I've since all
the little kid I wanted to be a rapper
and I started rapping when I was like 15
you know so um you already asked loud on
the ground no no I roll well fun there
were those when I first started rapping
those are the food I put her there when
I was like 17 18 they saw me at a show
and they put their arms around me and
we're like man you guys rap good but
your facts are wrong because my first
group goes called a Mexican descent and
we were just saying anything we're like
kids you know I mean I was like well
like like every James Olmos and all the
[ __ ] and then they'd be like you know
you know average is almost the
Republican you know they say some real
[ __ ] like oh [ __ ] to me like you're just
saying some [ __ ] I would say some [ __ ]
and they'd be like yo you rap
but your facts are wrong so learn your
facts so often underground with a fool
that that put me into the whole match I
know that you know though getting into
that Brown pride [ __ ] because I you know
I first started rapping I was just
saying anything on my ass and [ __ ] you
know I mean and it took off on
underground alike steered me in that
right direction issues so so yeah yeah
when I first started to like study
stand-up comedy like in the 90s but then
like late 90s I met um I don't know how
I got in touch with um somehow graphics
or like in the beginning you know they
had I don't even know that they had the
big space in Chavez and Chavez a dinner
space was that the old county jail at
first me okay I don't know how are you
hi yeah yeah the old county jail I don't
know that was their original space or
Cesar Chavez either way I met him there
a little sketch with them
oh the sketch group was called Kuzma oh
yeah yeah yeah I know talking about yeah
they are used to do all the little
little sketches
yeah they lose my help Chicano Secret
Service got a Secret Service yeah also
there yeah and so um I did mean Gabriel
it we did a show for them at UM at the
some of gravity the Chava huge bro
I still have somebody has to plot the
original flyer of all the people that
perform and I have a copy of it and I
have it some typos stood up but there's
a lot of people there man there was some
good good bands like I don't know if you
ever heard of East LA blues experiment
yeah that's hard they're still around
no right I've heard of them I think they
all broke I thought they broke out I've
seen one of the fools recently I think
they did other shady there's a band
around back in the really early 90s in
LA with like yeah Scott before they
began yeah so my little dolly and all
yeah way before all that yesterday mr.
Lee I blew this phony English yeah and
examine and oh sure our young fool to
and now they were representing back in
the day before the internet before all
that oh yeah all the ska bands that's a
self-help I used to go to self-help to
see all the like little ska bands and
[ __ ] although that you know that's what
other [ __ ] uh the sky women would be
a
[ __ ] totally DIY she's yeah oh yeah I
didn't Rudi's it on that chair
oh yeah the place I remember that show
was like all night it started like
around noon and it went to ten o'clock
and I perform in the daytime and I left
with Gable to do another show came back
at night time to hang out again they had
a food baby OJ's [ __ ] festival huh
yeah I remember one night all right
we did a show right and I remember I'm
some fool killed a mood bro what I saw I
went through a [ __ ] pun to say hey
dogs we were having a good time
rocky and he goes with the right he goes
up there and doesn't even do a poem he's
up all political like this anti-america
robber to punch him back to Mexico he
was like talking about like um put away
man he was talking about yeah man we're
all having a good time but right now a
man and Chiapas Mexico they're battling
they want to take some peasants land go
help him and I say bro ah I want to say
bro you know we have troubles here in
America let's cut the trade in one area
for some people they put their they put
their head on too many things but if we
call the trailer on one thing first
let's take care of Mexicans here in
America worse it's not we're about the
ones that are in Mexico oh yeah and
that's what that's that's what was
popping out there although you still a
college shows and all in like the Brown
Berets and like all the matches even
though the matches were kind of partied
out that you know I'm a light but the
Brown Berets that was really hardcore in
the 70 yeah eighties what do you guys
realize to look at me I caught the end
yeah I graduated 91 so or barely
graduated and anyone ever so I can't
look good my photos I thought you were
younger than that
no no I'm 44 doggone ah I am old it out
more than the game Valley we thought we
thought you were like rivers voices I
never had a job when you don't have a
job
you got to wake up for real we that's
how I wrote but people who looked bigger
may either bro what happened bro how'd
you stay so young hell you know at the
brook I had kids and I didn't give a
[ __ ] okay that's another thing never I
never had kids I like I just I have no
responsibility broke those are gotta
give me the best advice ever when I was
a struggling comedian I know you know
him - we had him here to juice one bro
I use one Magdaleno I think I'm gonna
get a big goatee long one
he's a lot schooled alright yeah yeah he
told me bro
you gotta keep your low overhead low bro
huh like don't be splitting a kind of
wild [ __ ] when you poke you in a shitty
apartment I was gonna have a nice we're
gonna have a couch hey Lily comes over
and you're joke man I lived in a couple
apartments with my homies and all we had
a little bit TV and nitendo when I shot
gun we didn't even have no [ __ ]
couches you just sat on the floor with a
[ __ ] shotgun in the window the war to
pop waiting for [ __ ] Mario Kart to
kick off you know recent we could play
Mario Kart and the loser would have to
wash the dishes or super [ __ ] like that
like we took that [ __ ] super to the
heart if you [ __ ] up at Mario Kart you'd
have to wash all the dishes cook do all
the [ __ ] you know saying and then
when we got him tomorrow car you he'll
know I was sorry I was done Nintendo the
first one I was done oh yeah mom went to
Madelyn and haven't stopped hope we have
oi I'm Aldo play Tecmo Bowl we had all
that Tecmo Bowl super tech mobile
evolved into that [ __ ] but that should
drains you doc I think I reach a patient
with 12 hours a day
what the [ __ ] you gonna do no life no
money no money no money and mario karta
nobody got no weed [ __ ] made me sleepy
do for a number when I was living like
like that I had a studio apartment you
know very tiny I was sober for a while
but after a while man what to tell it's
working weed I would like man how'd you
get high go to sleep [ __ ] Eddie
where were you getting your weed in the
in the in the late 80s early 90s or
little not the part I didn't smoke oh
you're right I did go to MacArthur Park
one time when I was like in the in the
late in the early 80s ladies and the guy
hoped it off for $60 okay
ya know some [ __ ] where there we see a
stress we should go get sack said we
should call a Salvi park but MacArthur
Park will you go get a [ __ ] dime
purple philosophy oh yeah oh yeah
Western and dammit maybe like 5 in the
morning even on Western and Pico trying
to find some nickel package it so you
also battle you to battle foolin rap
um not too much not too much I was more
like I came from this collective and on
Crenshaw on exposition called the good
life and when I first started rapping
there's this tool to open mic on
Thursday nights and it was a Muslim it
was a Muslim health food store and they
would turn it into an open mic and it
was all it was like 80% Muslim MC like
on some like X clan you know from
[ __ ] like extra [ __ ] awesome or
[ __ ] like the white man's the devil
[ __ ] or whatever and then it was like
15% Mexicans in there too and then my
first group of Mexican descent we went
there and we didn't get booed we didn't
get cheered and we didn't get booed but
we liked that there's so much we started
going there all the time and then we
just got we became part of that big
family even Mexican their interest they
were like they're like they're like
they're not rapping about you know we
cuz I wasn't rapping about lowriders and
[ __ ] like that because I didn't have it
like that out of the low church boy you
know but so I have that [ __ ] like that
I couldn't I don't want to rap about the
hood because I grew up in the hood and
you couldn't be no fake-ass you know I
wasn't gonna rap about [ __ ] I don't know
about you know me so yeah now we went
there and then we and then from there
man one of the group's there got signed
to Island Records and blew up and our
whole underground scene blew up and they
open the door for us and then man from
that they were called freestyle
fellowship their hardest [ __ ] man
they're from uh they're from LA they
were on some jazz [ __ ] you know who
stole their style with a bone
thugs-n-harmony you know for the letter
Delta they stole that that group stole
the style from freestyle fellowship but
they were they were on island Busta
Rhymes a lot of kind of the rappers I
rap all like super crazy fast jazzy they
these dues were jazz rappers they were
like there were young black kids but
they were rapping they were doing [ __ ]
that they were blowing people's minds
because yeah [ __ ] like that they were
run away before
oh man they're that Devil guy named
Micah 9 and he's like a jazz rapper like
it the way he would rap was like he
would like when you see him you would
think it was a it was weak and then 24
hours later you think of the greatest
[ __ ] you've ever seen you'd be like you
know it's a fight a fight under gun and
a white the way campfire but the [ __ ]
I decide out of mine at a time at a body
medical writing like and he started
doing all that you're gonna make me make
and all that weird [ __ ] and you're like
what is this [ __ ] jail
ish and then 24 hours later you were
like I can't stop listening to the [ __ ]
this is what the [ __ ] is he saying he's
saying like all you know they were jazz
rapping and so I kind of like learn from
groups like that to like listen to jazz
and that that imp that major Styles
better you know I mean we were my group
of Mexican descent we never like I said
we never rapped the butter like [ __ ]
and lowriders and [ __ ] we're rapping
more about like space and all kind of
weird [ __ ] because we're influenced by
full that we rap you know I'm super like
you know super crazier and [ __ ] you know
saying we got a lot of mushrooms back
there yes I did a lot of peyote and
mushrooms I'm one of those people that
does I don't smoke weed but I do more
like mushrooms and I do like D and T and
[ __ ] like that more like a person that
wants to be at the house going there and
[ __ ] I don't really focus t DMT that's
like you know it's like some uh it's
like a drug that when you smoke it it
kind of like it's like the same chemical
that releases in your brain when you
like have a hoard I remember when you
die it's [ __ ] pretty
ten minutes of like it's only like 12 13
minutes but if you do that [ __ ] I
videotaped my homies videotape me doing
that [ __ ] one time you basically smoke
that [ __ ] and then I try to stand up
like a banana and I just fell to the
ground and for 10 minutes lava is just
coming up on my bail or whatever but do
it in those 10 minutes dawg
it's amazing dude you you feel like you
feel like that game Tetris you're inside
that game to hear you leave Dawg you
like leave your body it depends I mean
it you have to do it you have to really
some the first couple times I did it to
be honest with you when it was over I
have a bad memory I couldn't say like
this is what happened and this is I was
like I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
but you feel like you meet God and all
this crazy [ __ ] but it gets crazy dude
it gets crazy I'm into hallucinogenics
you can add it to like a bong hit right
now oh yeah yeah you gotta hit it to
reach out you have to have a person
there I would do there that a
DMT coach yeah yeah hey for real and for
real though hey my wife's older don't
give ideas I miss to that so I miss the
shrooms all you're the third baseman I'm
saying I think I'm still fly yeah that's
that's me right there I'm I think I'm on
shrooms right now I could just picture
my ass to to body leaving my body boys
Oh God I come back and doesn't last that
long it doesn't last that long so you
cool man is doing it I got it
let me go look in the car I think that's
funny was the last time I put you
somewhere about drugs at that I lose
visions what some ecstasy when I was
there now Odessa Texas those are geysers
I love ya mom next by STP coach about
how you through bro so let you know what
happened to speak holy shocking she's
gonna [ __ ] squeeze your nipple [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't I don't [ __ ] with ecstasy
I'll [ __ ] with you never done it
nah not really I never [ __ ] with coke
and ever [ __ ] I got tricked into doing
coke me too ha ha ha over and over
hey I got tricked into doing it like
what just natural stuff like weed and
like yeah yeah oh the end that's it I've
never done acid I've never not like I
said coke only one time I got tricked
into a dog
I got become buddy somebody put that
[ __ ] in the joint and I wasn't paying
attention so poto yeah peyote is the
same Sheila peyote button that that's
also super intense I did that [ __ ] on
some Jim Morris I thought I was Jim
Morrison when I was little so I went out
there in the reservations with in New
Mexico and all that and so you know you
kick it with the natives and [ __ ] and
they put you up on game and you're out
there in the [ __ ] desert with a
gallon of water crying for your mom you
know some [ __ ] shows will feel for
your broad deal about king of the hill
bro all right when it took cotton yeah
thanks dad huh food super Yoda said that
Ted and you saw everybody and he saw
everybody was in there Ted would he look
like every Japanese he shot it World War
two wrong hey man I can't do it early
Amen I believe I've been laid out where
my face is on the dirt and I'm crying
for my mom hey you gotta go there man
and oh yeah you gotta try it
you gotta try to do like a life short
man sometimes you got to pee your pants
just to see God you know baby doesn't
need a doctor of your t-shirt bath come
on you gotta peel your path to the guy
man happened I haven't dug like he loved
me ah [ __ ] it
I had to marry poor old me bro the wrong
yada I'm seeing four on the floor what
happened get shit-faced dog we saw God
he's picked up
mule neighs over here dog that's what do
you say see God but what if you're not a
Christian you see your God you see a
specific God or do you see something
amenities that resemble God now I mean I
see [ __ ] when when [ __ ] like that
happens is more of a feeling though you
just look the lights everything [ __ ]
hit you and you're just kind of like you
start [ __ ] you got to start you start
talking to yourself because you're like
am I gonna die am I gonna what the
[ __ ] happening and then that's when
you learn how to master your high you
learn how to control yourself
I became mad at myself like you're doing
it you don't know what you know what I
do is like sometimes when the feelings
too crazy I throw my crutches hey dog I
was a mammal one time I like when my
home he passed away in my arms my best
friend member died in my arms and a year
later we all me and 20 friends were
swimming on his birthday and I had I'm
not joking man I was on the couch with
my sister and I had my armor on my
sister and when I look to the right my
sister was a wolf and on the real a and
I looked at myself and I when I get out
of a minute and I went like this and I
was like and I would like do I like we
all did you know where man is the
truthful you're gonna be all right
I still read it like that's the [ __ ]
that has the [ __ ] that happened dude and
you kind of like have to like she'll
over to talk to yourself and you got to
overcome that shouldn't be like you know
what that's just a [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] truth was gonna be our I forgot
my people I remind me of a see the
smiley face broke on Eternia she's
talking to the Sun you know that movie
hard to find
dude I look I've been looking for Nana
me but never they never have you dog put
yours on next level dobro every time I
see period of television never good I
don't know about all I'm telling you man
there I thought you doing in the
reservation right what I would do it
then you peel em yeah yeah I would do
with the right people I won't do it a
[ __ ] Burning Man but ceramic that
[ __ ] good black Foofa Riverside Mexican
food bro West Covina yeah I nobody
touching you [ __ ] you know I mean that
richness the xyx is the ecstasy coaches
there huh yeah extra so it's bad now but
I do show mostly man up your smoke it
smokers it's getting it now you could
take it in a button or you can make it
into tea
I mean you take that [ __ ] like you smoke
it it's not anything you can point you
today we'll do a lot of Native Americans
there or just going oh yeah I mean I've
done it I've done it like seven or eight
times so I mean a couple the first time
I did it I was with the natives out
there out there know Mexico and I was
like they were like putting me up on
game and they're like you either gonna
have a good time or not and the first
time I didn't have a good time but the
the second third fourth so on you you
Matt it's about mastering your high once
you take control of yourself and be like
I got this I know I'm [ __ ] tripping
but I got this and to me that's that's
what I like to be in control because
then after that you can start laughing
and everything's like okay you're flying
at least um I felt like I felt like you
see the movie the doors yeah that's not
a [ __ ] bad that's not a it's kind of
like I'm somewhere a [ __ ] Indian
comes out the desert you're a baby
oh I've got a [ __ ] little lamb comes
out I mean you should actually go down
like that like DMT is more like colors
and sounds because I'll listen to music
I'll be bumping music and then you close
my eyes and it just feels like colours
are raining down on you or like all kind
of like a Tetris like the game Tetris in
the game Tetris with a jokes come out so
imagine it's like you're inside the game
Tetris and it's just constant like
colored it's [ __ ] crazies all get
skeptical over here oh I mean you know
to do what is that new drug someone
talking about it madam it's like it's
almost a marijuana but not marijuana not
mafia no that's out yeah it's like spice
you take it right away
we take you take it at last a quick 30
to 10 seconds oh I don't know no sure
like that it's what I know is just that
DMT one it's just like that's the one
body will do it on their lunch break or
whatever that's the one you do different
revelry something yeah I mean that one
I mean I'm gonna tell you it's not
something you do on your lunch break
it's something you get ready for you to
do it like a ceremony like I think it
kind of seriously I wouldn't just be
like DMT is sitting on the table I'm not
[ __ ] with it let's building a Porsche
bro you gotta want to do it
yeah yeah you got to be in you're good
you have to be in a good mindset you
don't want no haters when I aim and let
me tell you when I first started taking
mushrooms I kicked it with some homies
and one of the homies was running around
with a knife trying to scare the [ __ ]
out of you and all that like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that's one of your little eye
when I was like 18 and [ __ ] my rooms are
really touchy everybody has to be on the
same
I like Jeannie by myself I render by
myself I myself yeah I'm at the house by
myself just like intense mood by myself
sorry Lisa yes I just over the band
that's when you can breathe if you have
enough room cuz it get to get to class
where my lady brought wanna cuddle she's
like giving me away I came here to be
off wing whistling order let me break it
down last week I assume right and I
started I'm watching YouTube and [ __ ]
I'm all laughing I [ __ ] see the WWF
oh yeah every day WWF wrestlers is
Jeannie seem that I don't know if you
guys like the WWE the rest yeah I'm
brilliant to that since ookay Nakamura
the new Asian food that comes out with
that dope as music yeah I started
geeking the [ __ ] out to him coming out
to that music right so I [ __ ] got so
high that I punched up his his theme
song and I wrote something to his theme
song and the next day I recorded it when
I woke up and now I made a remix to that
[ __ ] like that's what kind of should I
do
I'll be watching some crazy [ __ ] and
it'll leave me to writing and then I'll
write write to this wrestlers intro and
now I have a song or two it's on YouTube
hardest [ __ ] and I'll just make some
[ __ ] like that you know it is so that's
the kind of sort of to mix I've had one
bomb a treatment variance on TV not
shrooms was it in Frisco and this would
induce a tsunami and on this will give
it you guys are making a lot of noise I
kick you out it was so laughing louder
hey so we got all kind of scared right
and it's okay I want to go I'm gonna go
and it was just me Chris touring the
little guy whereas we had a little
person with us Oh
Julie who did this history store was
read my selfie here is like a little
tomato with a little full roll he was
trippin hard laughing it is adorable but
we were all laughing together in sync
Oh a full would hide and a dude would
look small and then a dude would look
super big Daniels I was just laying on
the bed every time I breathe I would
just take the world in it that's what
it's feeling good maybe I do the next
day I felt so calm and so relaxed full
for like two weeks I was just buying
yeah yeah when you feel that first hour
when it after that first hour they hate
you to me I feel translucent like
want to be outside with the wind blowing
because I feel almost like the winds
going through me it's crazy
yeah you know from the dirt or some yes
and some great ocean you know just opens
up a little chamber in your mind you
know it's something it's not I don't
recommend people to be doing this [ __ ]
and then they get all weirded out and
ship it to me shrooms is cool I've never
done asked ever and I'm telling you on
everything I love I've only done coke
once and I got tricked into it so it's
like that I choose my [ __ ] streak you
know well that not yeah I was at a
[ __ ] show in Oakland and uh some some
homies were rolling some joints on a
pool table and I'm sitting on the little
low chair so I can't really see the
angle and and dude I smoke they pass it
to me I [ __ ] smoke and I'm smoking
and do the little while later I start
being like we're about to play and I'm
like we're gonna [ __ ] it up we don't
kill it I'm all [ __ ] act you know
weird and [ __ ] then the performance III
guess I I was all crazy after the show
my boy was like do you smoke that joint
that they're rolling on the pool today
when I was like yeah he's like fully put
coke in it that's why I left and he out
like stupid why'd you [ __ ] tell me
dick
he didn't [ __ ] know you know Taylor
crack now I think it was cold ah who
knows uh all I know that I drove home
from Oakland to LA hey I drove home for
and then I know a man now I was scared
because it's so so good yeah it felt
like I was like I like I like oh this is
what it's like I like it's good it feels
like the worlds are calm and
everything's all peaceful or magua me
know what my experience was like it was
felt good talking out and it made me
worry doggone when I got home I sat on
my porch like and I'm gonna want more
about [ __ ] trippy but oh well more
like oh my ting but I missed oh yeah
something I feel like you know Kabir I'm
a drug addict you know the crackhead
but see that's some time inthis I really
like joint at the man you're like oh I
wonder what this good ass weed right
here this Louie the third time somebody
[ __ ] and when I would it tastes like
with a bad ass piece of crack in it or
you should have a sprinkle just a little
sprinkle but see that's my mind find you
another way to get back to to you doing
crack again my eyes if my mind will
always you know the miles away thinking
and I think like my mind it misses it
you know I don't physically but our mind
does is cook okay - the main thing yeah
so it'll try to find the taste somehow
like I'll have you suck
you know maybe you just smoke a primo
this time you know yeah it's like we
stop drinking it goes now what is gonna
be wine yeah we'll do drugs [ __ ] feel
good that's why everybody's [ __ ] like
so because they feel good at the bottom
line you're not thinking about your
health or your repercussions or your
future or your finances you talking
about now you don't man yeah I don't
drink alcohol man I don't I haven't
drank a beer in [ __ ] five years ago I
have my own beer and I don't even drink
I don't like my own IPA Doug and I never
drank like half of one like me like as
soon as I start like like want to do
that and they're like I don't do it but
then I get a urge to eat something that
some type of food but I lose weight I
say [ __ ] that I'm gonna go eat it yeah
yeah I mean I had a homemade old
addicted to heroin and he would look at
me be like whoo I'm only doing coke like
you know any of you like I'm not at
least I'm not on heroin this will be
chopping up a pill all into heroin aim
and it will be chopping up some pill and
he's looking at me like at least I'm not
on heroin and I'm like is that an excuse
without that I worked in making it an
excuse
how I look I think did that coke like
what it was a supercharged
no yeah wolfhard I was pissed when my
mommy told me that [ __ ] we were driving
home leaving the show in Oakland going
we're gonna go get a hotel because we
got paid good and so we were gonna go
get a hotel like you know you don't want
to stay in Frisco because it cost too
much yeah we were leaving so like let's
just go to San Jose get a room and then
I started driving and when he told me
that was like what I was all mad and you
know like okay that explains what the
[ __ ] I'm act
I feel like I feel and then after that
my homey just passed out and I was like
I'll get that we'll go get a room and
then I was like oh now I know what
cocaine feels so wonderful it felt like
the whole universe was in sync or
whatever and then I and then honestly I
just kept driving and driving and
driving and when since the fool passed
out I just next thing you know I'm
[ __ ] halfway to LA I'm gonna great I
like I might also go the [ __ ] home
and when you see that yeah I don't
realize that but yeah when you still
about that's why I do what cocaine is so
good because it feels good I just
thought about it nah man I've done
cocaine with three dudes five dudes and
the whole time were hyper conversations
I'm really having a good time because in
the back of my head you know all those
problems that you
like if you're stressing about the money
and I'll just read about like you just
press apply your not having enough money
for the Kington yeah now or you don't
have money for your bills your cheek
don't want you no more man you get a
six-pack and have for 8-ball couple of
friends [ __ ] darts whatever what are
we gonna do cars conky on play spades
time what nothing is I realize we're
talking a lifetime remember tell him
your life for a living our pan when you
calm down or mad at the most it's like
falling off a pair of shoe and no
parachute bro sad honestly man yeah I'm
lucky dog that that shouldn't it didn't
give me without though I never got
hooked on that [ __ ] I don't even
understand that because you can have all
that fun without the coke cuz remember
that one time [ __ ] is good for one
time I did coke this fool I think this
[ __ ] sold his chalk dude come on
it was I do that I [ __ ] I do you a
great [ __ ] liner with ocular human
being that piece of [ __ ] from dude [ __ ]
that guy dawg dude I'm in there boy did
I did I couldn't even put out I do it it
wasn't cocaine I know was it cocaine oh
yeah they just did you dirty was alright
[ __ ] it I [ __ ] forty bucks to
who I was when I was young I people used
to you know when you're musician you
know at the at the end of the night to
give you weed coke but I should get coke
and gets so scared I would just flush it
down the toilet because I was like I
don't want that [ __ ] I don't want like
soul
parrot cuz I grew up in a crack
neighborhood so I've seen like I'll
sorry about the hookers earlier I've
seen I seen I grew up in the
neighborhood where the hookers used to
be fine and they crack it and then they
turned into zombies so like I was always
as a little kid I remember seeing
hookers looking fine and then seeing
crack just devastate my neighborhood in
mid-city California and just turned
people into zombies and cry and you know
I'm walking home from school with
zombies coming out the [ __ ] alley and
[ __ ] people they used to look good yeah
yeah yeah and then all my friend man all
my friends man like uh not all my
friends but a lot of my friends I've
seen them coke was the one thing that
I've seen them go through even more than
that I was like method suppose to me
looks weirder but I've seen a lot of
people go to coke or like it really just
[ __ ] like losing teeth and just doing
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and like you
know it's not them when you're caught up
in the game any
really you that's your you're out of
your own character is just a [ __ ] talk
you gotta make that [ __ ] crack because
you got to make you gotta [ __ ] get to
that next you got to get that next
twenty bucks and I mean so it's like you
your mind that's what [ __ ] stop
stealing your stereo then I grew up in
the era with that with the pullout yeah
came with a foot wheelchair in a motor
little bags locked my UC fool died
October though had the faceless so when
they tell ya my neighbors have some some
neighbors from inside although uh and
one of my one of my boys was caught up
in the game like that and dude I would
get home at 3:00 4:00 in the morning and
this was just chillin in front of his
house and do it eventually that fool
took my stereo and I was like down from
your neighbor dog like don't you know
least I can go to the next block like
this you know I mean but when you get to
that point you know it goes I grew up in
that I grew up in a crazy hustling
neighborhood where I seen pimps at a
young age
and so like the concept of pimping and
holes and and serving and hustling man I
like I kind of like since I was like
little I seen that so I kind of never
thought it was weird maybe your friends
grew up in be pimps yeah I got hungry
homies in my crew that are pimps now how
they started out how they start gave a
first hole because they just had gave
other unknown Andre had they just had
game from birth some fools just have
game from automatic like that's we talk
let me tell you my homies a pimp I won't
name them but my homie one time he was
giving us a ride to the studio and when
you pick this up he had a girl with us a
girl and the whole time he's talking all
this tension to it like aid
let your next step be your best bet
bothers pimp talk and he dropped her off
and this he drop her off and he made it
when you dropped it off he made sure
that he dropped her off on this exact
little spot like how to wait and park in
his exact spot and when he dropped off
you know yeah you know British call me
whatever and when we left we were
laughing at him like what are you doing
he goes that's exactly where I dropped
her off that's the exact foot that I
picked her up at because he wanted to
psychologically let her know that when
he picked that when he dropped her off
he wasn't taking her nowhere if she
wasn't [ __ ] with him like she's like
he didn't give her a ride home he
dropped her off and in the exact spot
where he picked her up to not be like
you ain't getting [ __ ] from me unless
I'm your pimp like you know just high
weird high level game [ __ ]
that like just the way you talk I grew
up a fool that just talked pimp talking
I seen fools man I got homies that they
just every now and then they send me
text messages were like they're like yo
I got these porn stars for two days
do you know anybody not just be like no
but send me the picture just don't
really look like anyway you know but
like you know it's like fools I don't
fool that pimp
I just pimp out yeah it's all game dude
it's all psychological game do I want to
read a great book about what two men
talking about go buy that books iceberg
slim oh yeah it's an awesome book of a
prostitution prostituting it was given
to me by brother woods and it breaks
down the pimp game like you wouldn't
believe
it's written by as a documentary this
documentary about him getting where he
breaks down how he was just pimping shut
it off you know it's a good story it
talks about I got like man the end is
kind of sad I kind of a sad story at the
end but um he brings his down man this
pimp it would like he was pimping in
1940s this guy oh yeah and he had a
[ __ ] dog a Cadillac of a year cash
bro and then like this is what I'll just
break it down like what he said was
another you're talking about it could
you saw it firsthand
and um he goes up he goes when another
pimp was school in this Pam iceberg
about the pimp game he goes like oh he
goes like drive two hours to another
hood and he talks to this pimp
he'll yeah man one of these hoes is
trippin he'll well man we know when a
hos tripping he I remember that
that [ __ ] is saving up money that [ __ ]
holding onto money somewhere it's try
and get away he's trying to get away so
she shallow attitude
so you gotta tell the whole the right
things you know so they whatever the
cover they should go he goes back to
this hole so he talked to her and he go
anything like he tells her like this is
that you know he tells her yeah man I'm
I saw a lot of town but just came back
from across town I got these other hoes
over there working for me now I got
these other whole works he did he know
and I'm pretty much to let her know
whether by the way that he don't really
need her
right right then he starts talking in
that business getting sad and she gives
up all the money you can use Harley like
a logic tells her to leave told her
leave and then he but she begs to come
back bro yeah that's because it's all
psychological you know it's just that
like you know some people just naturally
are charismatic and they just could have
mine control over people and it's just I
mean unfortunately it's satisfied it's
just getting kind of sad this
conversation but unfortunately it's just
a way of the world because a lot of
people try to pimp you in another way so
it's like whether it's sexually or your
body or mentally or pimp just people who
try to pimp you out and work just give
me another pimping fake comedy bro Oh a
for real dawg irrelevant hey there's a
lot of right I [ __ ] hate all these
mumble mouth piece of [ __ ] what brower's
oh I say whack [ __ ] [ __ ] these fools
like yeah they're just pimping a lot of
fools are just saying anything I
watching I like you know the [ __ ] I
don't know how it is in the I love
hip-hop helping Tommy and the hip-hop
game but I tell you in comedy now
there's people out there that all
that'll chance time start off with one
video write one sketch video and guys
like what for views that's it but that
for use those for view 40,000 beautiful
4,000 views yeah to start this and then
they have comedy shows the I prefer
let's come here that I'm that make deals
like remember that comedy show that
Rizal did where everybody got paid 100
hundred dollars right all right the toy
all this comedian got be 150 bucks $200
500 to be on this tape and then that guy
sold it for her network yeah and he
makes all the advertisement he makes
money forever ties when these
communities don't get nothing hey we're
all day I got a tattoo bro all dude I've
been man I've been playing for my dog
hey exposure bros and flipping her hey
my homies that a we know means to have a
management company and it was called no
pounds because it was like yo none of
this [ __ ] none of that I ain't no you're
doing it for the culture not on me I got
to pay my bills on me the culture don't
pay my bills you know I'm saying yeah
now I mean we all get pants when you get
in the game
whether it's a comedy game the movie
the music game when you come in you just
trying to get your feet wet and doin
anything so fool that you know you
getting paid 20 bucks or man there was
times where I would drive damn near the
Fresno to get paid just gas money just
to play in front of 40 people because I
was just trying to like back in the day
I would only get it one show every six
months so I was like I didn't give a
[ __ ] about playing for free I didn't
give a [ __ ] about doing whatever yup
I've [ __ ] to chose and outside about
I just show them a [ __ ] ice cream
truck you know I mean I performed in a
little league baseball banquet like
[ __ ] don't even want to hear
you rapping in the mariana baseball
field like you know like when you when
you're so trying to get into the game
you know that those are the moments when
you're getting pimped and then once you
gain your own power and you see what's
really going on and hopefully you can be
in control of your own situation yeah I
mean you were done of course you've done
it man what does this or jiggle
poor form he did a show one time and he
who that we've all we both been able
recently he goes he did a comedy show he
had what was the stage and the stage was
a truck bed a long one at the 18-wheeler
oh yeah I had all of the other equipment
right there and everything all in one of
the comedian's that he was with a limp
ever fell oh this full has a little a
little little lamp ha [ __ ] a mic
cable cut this fools foot Oh God bailed
into the drum set like a little
helicopter all the dungeons some man
I've just shows where I did a show us
and Crenshaw with it it was all a black
church and bright before I perform and
right before I perform five or six
people came up crying talking about
somebody in the family died and all this
violence and in their life and now we
got this guy and I'm like ah I literally
everybody's sad about like [ __ ]
police violence and then I'm supposed to
[ __ ] come on and be all like like we
got this Mexican dude you know trying to
show black and brown unity because my
name is to max I get to get both for car
shows and [ __ ] like that and I'm not
really a car show rapper like I left you
know if you listen to my music it's I'm
not even dissing partial rappers because
I'll play any car show but I'm just
saying I'm not I'm not
rapper that necessarily raps about
certain kind of things that people think
to Mex Chicano rapper that's what I
thought yeah yeah a lot of cat I listen
a tune that a call you later yeah it's
on a different level
yeah yeah and a lot of cats I was used
to go to Texas and Arizona and Colorado
and I'd be at a car show with kit for
all and slow makes it good Oh South Park
Mexican all those dudes right and dude
I'm coming up here like like like I said
my music if y'all check out my music my
music much I said dope dope or anything
but I'm just much it's different and so
I'm out there at the car shows and after
I perform the dues pay me always like
yeah you know yeah it was cool man but
you know you wonder what I thought you
know they just said to mix rapper
Chicano rapper from Los Angeles they
tell him about the rap universe app and
Roger and [ __ ] and I'm sure rappin with
the Mexican flag behind you oh yeah
didn't I mean - my name is - Mex where
people don't understand it when I I name
myself to mix and a Mexican cent I was
16 years old so like to mix like I'm too
proud to be Mexicans trying to find
myself but next but I don't necessarily
we we don't rap over like salsa or
[ __ ] you know cumbias and [ __ ] like
we I'm just never jazz funk yeah I never
try to stay in that box you know because
I didn't want to be a found underground
in the Chicano Movement that whole
self-help graphics in East LA and the
metal another [ __ ] to me sometimes I
felt like when you're in a box I feel
like they'll put you in that Chicano box
where you're like you're that
revolutionary dude and that's what you
are
you're only the [ __ ] chair t-shirt
wearing this thing and now I'm not I'm
Way more than that I like I like I like
rap I like funny [ __ ] I like a rap about
women are above all kind of [ __ ] you
know I mean like it just depends I rap
about things that just enjoy me and like
our music is like a little harder to
Chicano rap doesn't really love me like
that
brothers like Kip frost I built with Kip
Frost and a lot of brothers
oh Jesus but like Chicano rappers or not
I'm not really like a fan or their now I
fancy I mean you don't see my [ __ ] in
that you gonna rap with little Rob and
on a [ __ ] you know mean Capone mr.
Caponi yeah all that [ __ ] I don't never
do connect oh yeah I remember all those
dudes man and and and I would be in
those circles it's just that my group my
first group of Mexican descent do
My partner chill isn't my partner's name
is cholo lon Cinco he was really out
there because he was an improvisational
jazz rapper so our you know our stuff is
like we were over there trying to be
jazz rappers and in a world of of
lowrider music you know things I wasn't
always fitting so when you're not um out
there doing some DM tees do mushroom
would you like et what's your favorite
type of food my favorite type of food is
Thai food
oh yeah that's a long time though it's
funny the way over here I'll show show
my wife sometime my Instagram I get food
you know what I follow pool all the time
yeah follow rabbits for about you know
sake I know and um sticky rice and mango
man oh yes I'm a scissor dog a Thai food
all day man um ultra-pure Thai place
original Thai barbecue on Normandy uh
Normandy and a third they got a bunch of
them they got like ten of them but
original Thai barbecue Tora Oh Cho Cho
cha what is that what is called okay the
red red red one
yeah it's got a little yeah yeah it's a
little chain huh yeah that's the best
one has to win that's what will you tell
them on Normandy enter handl [ __ ] big
ass like on Sunday that's my sense of
that fish oh okay I like that I like
that Tom Kukai that coconut milk soya
and then I like pineapple fried rice so
that's my favorite give me the chills on
that Tom Cubs to Comcast when it comes a
little flame yeah yeah that's is what
that's my favorite food we should do
stand-up comedy shows and I'm late at
night we should go to eat Thai food in
Hollywood tais-toi yeah so Rosie yeah
it's all wrong I could close it at 4:00
a.m. yeah it's better brother gasping
[ __ ] yeah I go to a lot do five that's
my physical late at night we cheat
Rani's in there all the Hollywood world
is there like hipsters right Frannie's
cholos Doug we should do the same [ __ ]
man me and my homie I have a rapper
friend named bus driver and two three in
the morning yeah
as his name is butch a transfer yeah
exactly and we would you know the show
then that to your outside selling CDs
you know doing your thing no dude I
gotta hustle
I'll just seat man underground
Hustler dog too short you know yes sir
- sure taught me - sure taught me you
know that I mean I honestly man I
probably your merge machine oh man I not
so my the pain pills right but I used to
all man back when CDs were worth
something
[ __ ] yeah dude we would go I would we
would go to San Francisco not even be on
the bill and drop me and my homie would
drive there and we both make eight
hundred bucks a night and we would just
split the gas going home we'd be like we
weren't even playing we would just be
like all this group that's in our
universe that we know is the [ __ ] and we
know they're fans like our [ __ ] and we
would just go there and stand outside
with a box of CDs ten bucks all day like
back in the day when CDs were worth
something
now it's like people are like they're
not they're not into like everything
that they steal everything I mean but
it's all good and [ __ ] so um you've also
merged shirts oh yeah yeah I saw shirts
I'm so hats and [ __ ] I used to sew
man I got a homie with a laser engraver
so I should so like hearings for girls
wallets with my [ __ ] face on it
wallet Oh [ __ ] flasks little flasks
and [ __ ] with my faith my logos you know
that of that family logo of under the
giant okay
we flip that logo way back in the day so
that's been my that obey logo is my logo
to like to mix with the with the under
the giant so do that such a recognizable
logo I will put it on wallets I will put
it on shot glasses I you know whatever
leg as you ever lego chima run into a
fan that has your original shirt and
you're like whoa yeah I'll do my my like
my fans got ah there's hundreds of
people and I'm not exaggerating there's
hundreds of people with my face tattooed
on their body like that logo like with
on their arm and people tap my lyrics on
have a call like a cult following so
like the people that love me
they [ __ ] really like did name their
kids after I do this thing called to mix
custom songs where I write songs like
I'll write a song for your girl so you
tell me like yo my girl's name is this
we've been together we got married on
December 25th whatever and I'll take
that like those four paragraphs and I
will make a song like you're talking to
your girl like a romantic song second
and do brilliant [ __ ] yeah back on that
pimpish [ __ ] and dude I'm telling you
these songs have led to kids being born
marriages whose cheat on their lady
[ __ ] on the lady and theirs in the
doghouse and then I make them the song
and the lady took them back like I'm
awesome
right and I'll burn a new lady I really
want to go back in the days hey after I
do I wasn't girl walking to girls catch
me cheating at the same time yeah I got
all that [ __ ] I got one where a chick it
was a girl writing it to her to her man
and it was like yo even though you
cheated on me we have a kid and [ __ ] it
out I can get over it and let's stay
together like [ __ ] like that dawg I make
songs for people for their kids I make
songs for people for themselves like one
girl she would like make me a song about
how beautiful I am and imma [ __ ] and I
was like what you want and she wanted
the Kanye West workout plan which is
like a fast beat so I made her song
about how wonderful she is
and every day we she wakes up in the
morning and goes to the gym she listens
to a song about how beautiful she is
and so I'll make a song for her like
that for just like 200 bucks and they
keep the song forever like a [ __ ]
sell it put it on YouTube and go [ __ ] I
do that every day will do those comedy
jingles yeah it is like that it's like
Mad Men it's like Adam probably jingles
Romilly left with rookie giver yeah man
yeah me hey a little laugh a man I'd
make sure like that did I do songs for
people like and people get crazy with
the songs I told Alessa what I don't
want popular ever t-shirt you ever made
most popular t-shirt I made a PETA shirt
like PETA you're vegan no no I try to be
it depends and I was vegan like four
days ago well yeah but then I went to
Burger King City I got paid shade under
my burger yeah yeah I'm like I'm Lee I
do like one you know a little video yeah
I was vegan like four to two days like
the other day and then I'll go and I
won't but I have a shirt I had a PETA
shirt like People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals
but I flew it was like People for the
Ethical Treatment of Alex which is my
name Alex so I was like I'll make my own
Peter shirt you know I mean [ __ ] like
that like stupid little flips like that
you know you know a show coming up um
I'm trying to think what's the next show
yeah you know what I'm hosting a I'm
hosting paid dues this year which is a
little wayne-o at school and if a cooler
it shows another big world of little one
um it's big it's like 7,000 people and
one over there in Orange County and at
the orange which is it that a weeks ago
yeah we just did a well this last
Saturday my other band called
visionaries we played at the National
orange show and then a week before that
we sold out the observatory and sauna it
was a festival the little underground
routes up so where's paid dudes at this
it's going to be a Pershing Square oh
really yeah free night nah that looks
yeah yeah but it's like little Wayne and
your hosted red man yeah yeah yeah I
kind of every year that paid dues
happens
I either hold it or perform at it but
it's better for me to host because I an
LA I play all the time so I'm kind of
played out in the city because I I play
a little bars and [ __ ] all the time so
I'd rather hold because for six instead
of playing for 20 minutes I'd rather
hold for six hours because I could get
my agenda off for six hours and you're
on the tablet when you're on that stupid
teletran or whatever it's enormous
its enormous dog and you know what your
exposure blows up and I get more work
after pay dues because food will be like
they think it's more bigger than what
the [ __ ] it is you know I mean never
mind they're like there's not the focus
on stage at the little Winchell you know
even though it's not that much it's not
all that but it's like that imagery will
get you more work so to me like I like
doing [ __ ] like that I like hosting man
I like I got a radio show radio station
I like do I like I'm more like it I'm 44
how I got one leg though what am I gonna
be [ __ ] put your hands in the air at
50 you know to me my music is dope
though American so dog but I'm not going
to be [ __ ] like 50 years old like put
your [ __ ] hands in the air dog like
like I'm like transferring into like
writing and doing some others you've
been putting out records since 2000
right
I've been putting our records I put out
my first record in 1996 oh that's the
first one I'm Mexican the same those my
first TV credit with Anthony's yeah back
in the day with our show - and legendary
six
yeah that's I've been putting in work
since I started rapping in 91 and then I
started I finally put something uh it's
called exitos in my sexy toes and I was
like a ninety six ninety who's been like
your biggest inspiration in cotton rap
um that's like a question dude I was
always you know what
definitely my god am I sound corny but
probably the great I mean the greatest
rapper in the world scare is one from
boogie dumb / ee he's a piece of best
rapper ever man so like a dude like that
it's probably like one of my biggest
influences because
so that you let get you low and the
gangly dog because he's mad knowledge
reps yeah yeah exactly I'm into that man
I need any music that uh I need somebody
to blow my mind when I hear song I can't
listen the stupid [ __ ] about dumb [ __ ]
like I need to hear somebody say
something that that kind of blows on
mine or else I get bored ugh
it's like porno when you watch too much
porn oh you're like desensitized to the
weak [ __ ] it's like I need to since I
watch your bloopers yeah look at that
boys comedy bloopers for a man or girl
blowing somebody other southern ah they
walk away technical Ashley nobody you're
cut
yeah man [ __ ] like that I'm into food
that I really like but some never have
anybody like a lot of the way help you
like or like you know like I know for me
you know like as a comedian you know
like people say well nobody really
helped me but I think a lot of people
help me in even Big Dawg you know where
whoever lot for me anybody was ever
given me a pledge perform or had ever
paid me to perform or but like you get
you get like very um you get you get
down you get very distracted you know
you're not making no money or you see
other people moving up and you're not
moving up but along the way like I've
had people help me to keep me for could
be looking forward at Paul Rodriguez
like you hooked me up with a gig that
paid a lot of money hands up for him and
that really helped me a lot to not get
discouraged to give up ya know cuz a
little every little thing though it
helped me you know like maybe like I get
a phone call for somebody that then
called me in five years to open up for
them in the beginning and I go wow this
guy's calling me that's good so I'm I'm
relevant if that's how I feel when you
today that's how I a that's also when
y'all hit me up to do this man like I
really like I'm a big fan man and I
don't wait yeah man there's always been
any time you get something any time you
get something that you think it's cool I
think we're all really cool level you're
here I appreciate that man but wherever
I mean yeah there's always been people
like us on underground and there's
always been like back in the day there
was there's a rap group there's their
big now still they're called a living
legend and they put me on my first like
37 city tour back Wow when I was like I
had never really left California you
know and they put me on a 37 city tour
there's another rapper from LA
underground
abstract rude he could be the first
person that take me to Canada or you
know I mean like I played in 22
countries like I've been blessed I mean
but like it there's different people
along the way were you yet sometimes
things are going tough and then you get
that one television gig or you get that
one big I play a lot of small bars and
clubs but if seven eight nine times a
year I get to play pay dues or something
where there's 10,000 people five
thousand people then it offsets all the
groundwork just like comedians are all
the [ __ ] open mics and all the little
things that that you do you do 24 or 30
of those to hit but then you get you
know if every six months or every three
months you can get that one thing that
keeps you like relevant that's a good
way to put it man it's like that
I'll be doing stuff and then boom I'll
have a show that like really keeps me
relevant I'm playing one in September in
Long Beach called music tastes good and
it's got all these bands that I used to
like when I was like sleater-kinney and
all these kind of bands and like rap you
know every now and then you get that
festival that like puts you you know
that puts you makes you look good for a
couple months and you could kind of live
off of that that same you know what I
mean pay dues man like pay dues be like
the kind of festival wave so I can use
it whenever look I'm only popular the
week of [ __ ] like that when I'm playing
on his [ __ ] West Covina Katie shakes
when I'm playing I wear a when I'm
playing at Katie Jake's for seven people
no one gives a [ __ ] when I'm [ __ ]
playing I paid dues then I'm everybody
everybody wants to be my [ __ ]
girlfriend can I get in for two weeks a
phone call a bra have a wrapper yeah oh
yeah I'll do with that whenever big
concert comes that's not a phone call
what's up baby how you been I like be
like [ __ ] you don't know me like you
didn't like me you didn't come see me
last week when I played in a [ __ ] for
somebody's grandma and [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] backyard you know I mean like I
know I can see when people like just
when you have the popular [ __ ] I could
see through the people and that's why I
look at all your DM I'll do it i hook up
I actually my real fans the ones that do
come to the bars those are the ones that
I hook up with the free $80 tickets the
ones that like come see me on a 500 yeah
I got a homie named Bruce and dude this
guy my saw Bruce what's up bring
everybody's a fan he probably comes 15
times a years in my shoulder man so
whenever so if he needs that that $80
discount i'ma lay some
$80 one [ __ ] lay some bro oh yeah
much lease was legal Mace's boo yeah
member yeah man so it's right right a
little anything along the way like a
phone call that she keeps you [ __ ] in
the mix da all that she did do done I'm
telling you man gone but not forgotten
dawg I try to hook up some people map
call him people sometimes but you know
in the past oh man I can't go why
something when I caught it again oh dude
he doesn't know right you know play
basketball yeah we're gonna do this get
back to always be there man over here
[ __ ] getting night that you're like
[ __ ] the serum let me tell you man let
me tell you I'll tell you a quick story
this is this is a lesson this is the
lesson for all underground artist of any
kind my first group of Mexican descent
we used to play in San Bernardino and a
Riverside for ten people like we would
go play out there every couple months
for ten people five people ten people 12
years later one day these two Native
brothers come up to me and they're like
do you remember us and we're like yeah
they're like you used to come play for
us for like ten people and then one time
we didn't have no money and you sold me
a CD for like a dollar and I was like
instead of ten another gas let go
another time after the show our car
broke down and you drove by him and
checked up to make sure we were good not
like okay
these dudes turned out to be the Indians
from the salmon oil casino and for like
three or four years these news came back
ten years later and they funded me and
my whole crew to the tune of like a
quarter of a million dollars from when
they were these kids we we should go
play for ten people and this one brother
his brother named Craig was up Craig and
and Danny and they and these two
brothers their cousins these two cousins
straight-up funded me and my whole crew
for like half a decade I'm talking about
here's 20 racks here's 30 racks here's
the 50 rags like for a couple years
because because when we played for five
people it was one of those five people
so I always tell all artists do whether
you playing for five people or 5,000 you
better act when you're playing for five
people perform like you're playing for
5,000
the someone that like really loves you
so much a fan I have an album called my
fan base what
destroy you and that's why it's called
my fan base will destroy you because one
fan can can change your whole scope and
your family's life and for me that
happened for me and all my crew like
maybe like five years ago and that's the
kind of [ __ ] that happens like one
person the power that your music affects
one person could like kid like just that
one person could see what you see and
and it's like for them it was like
philanthropy and they [ __ ] just lace
me and all my friends man that's some
real [ __ ] you know hell yeah
[ __ ] getting lace nice I'm telling
you doggy with one dude man like I see
your reader fat of course man the
greatest ever dog Ali readers are solid
I can go clean ever the greatest Romero
dog hell yeah hey I got this when they
were I got a Raider touch on my right
hand I got this one they were 2 and 14
the year that they won two games in lost
14 that's what I was like ok it's my
time they need my help
[Laughter]
that's how hard I write for my radio dog
legs like you know yeah beuter soldier
dude if it wasn't for this what happened
with my leg dog I was going to go see
them in Mexico City when they played a
first time and this year I'm trying to
go this airplane the Patriots compared
to the page you don't want the pictures
to not even exit the building for I want
them to be like like like some weird
[ __ ] where like like that laughs I
killed them all in jail awesome crazy
[ __ ] like they killed the [ __ ]
Raiders the Raider fans actually murder
murder I'm just kidding well we're
delicious people there oh yeah man
everywhere dawg everywhere I go there's
times where I'm in Colorado or anywhere
in the United States and I'll be at a
Denny's or something and right when it's
time to pay the wages of the waiter be
like no you're good Raider Nation I'll
put that on I mean I'll get hey two
people hate on you two but I swear it
out one one time my homie Pablo he's a
Raider fan so we got in a car accident
and this fool here to Jamaican food and
man this Jamaican food was big dog and
he he was [ __ ] peers and you're about
to [ __ ] my homie Pablo up like we're
about to have to fight this buff
Jamaican food and this fool was yelling
I'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you know what and then he goes you're
locking your homies a Raider fan you're
good and
[ __ ] inside of his truck say like waiter
nation and because I was a Raider friend
- he [ __ ] didn't beat the [ __ ] out of
my home you know like reader nation
itself a it goes out like that dude like
that's all type of mission is on it is
our hug now I believe I do
imagine a team sucking for 13 years and
we just win one game and we think with a
[ __ ] maybe Raiders gave one touchdown
and we walk around for three weeks like
yeah [ __ ] you know like [ __ ]
do we suffered long enough I celebrate
the first half only the Raiders are
playing the Los Angeles chargers in
Inglewood Christmas Eve oh man yeah yeah
Christmas Eve babe Year's Eve the Los
Angeles chargers of Anaheim followed
Angeles chargers of Anaheim a San Diego
man playing the Oakland Raiders I had a
Vegas are starting at 350 bucks I'll see
it on TV though yeah now I'm gonna watch
it on TV I rather watch it on TV
I put a goalie bro the charge is to hang
out at the tailgate and then yeah yeah
that's probably a good I walk around
broke pass out flyers and perform in
here hey hey I do the same I've done
every four bro I went to a Raider game
with my podcast equipment how you guys
doing good
that's what's up though oh yeah I've
gone to the Raider I went to the Raider
uh they do something at the beach they
do something in Newport Beach every year
it's like the Raider Booster Club and
fall dude it's like 5,000 Raider fans
barbecue know about social with a pirate
ship in well dude now that I lost my leg
I became the [ __ ] Raider logo it
turned into the pirate I turned into a
[ __ ] tattoo dude that's what I'm
gonna be for Halloween finally I got my
permanent Halloween
it'll be shameless growth for Family Guy
oh [ __ ]
alright it's a mast and do it like now
that I'm a [ __ ] pirate do but the
world opened up to me man it's crazy
dude I could put weed in here and sneak
it into a party [ __ ] fresh dude I'm
fully met when I feel about you know
that one leg we locked it I think about
that up when I when I saw the rap video
in this job this this Samoan guy with
one leg as rat as a daddy bro oh yeah I
want oh
should not do that one never know oh man
they play that way oh man it's something
a rap song and I think it's our one
latest homeboy from Birdman oh yeah
Birdman song and then like you know
something just up breaking a song cook
tuna turn turn then I little this
[ __ ] gangster a Samoan dude with
ponytails shows up he dancing too
broadly [ __ ] it through the Crutcher
that are hopping broke oh [ __ ] yeah when
we get up little arrow I'll do it ever
since this should happen to me every day
of my life because this happened to me
for some reason people think that I want
to see every video ever of anybody with
one leg doing anything mother [ __ ]
misty way to [ __ ] I'm like okay dig like
I get it we got one later I'll do food
with one leg breaking little kids
playing basketball like everything that
happens with one leg I get that video
dog everyday life are they show every
day but we have both legs over the
shoulder our fast food do you know what
I'll do row a that's what happened dog I
was guilty of meat okay so especially it
could be me - cause it cancer
um I mean to everything both everything
out here is poisoning us straight up
yeah bro yeah that I have everything
done but you know for me I mean the
doctor told me after I talked after I
interviewed he interviewed me I told him
that pretty much like will [ __ ] me up
and I was drinking a two liter coke a
day Gatorade I mean I was [ __ ] me up
Wednesday no water huh I drank water but
not enough to all I drank with sodas
okay oh yeah now I will that do you know
the double big gulps at 7-eleven that's
me right there the tea mom hey I would
drive around in one day get a double of
Big O and stop a 7-eleven like three
times before he left the legs what did
you feel first he doesn't just happen
slowly or get happy all at once now the
first thing I felt was uh on the bottom
of my foot dizzy
I had a callus and I peeled a callus and
I had this thing called a diabetic
stress ulcer and it was like a little
like a little spider bite like a little
wacko and [ __ ] and I was like a wet ball
yeah dog and I was like so I looked
online and I read up on the [ __ ] and I
started putting like they said manuka
honey
you know sort of putting patches and it
started healing that was on my veil
about my left foot and then on my right
foot once I got one on my right foot you
know like oh [ __ ] and then and then
literally man a couple weeks later my
leg swelled up like my foots all over
like a football and my leg was hurting
but of course dude I'm Mexican food so
I'm like yeah I'm gonna go to the doctor
they gave me a couple days I'm busy and
I kept [ __ ] putting it off like seven
eight days and then I started slipping
into a coma I did a show where I had to
sit down in the chair and I couldn't
remember my rhymes dog and I was like
starting to slip into a coma
excuse me and then uh on the day where I
called my sister to a take me to the
hospital like something's wrong right
when she was coming to get me
I [ __ ] was like oh yeah let me get up
in pee and I went to piss and by the
time I got to the bathroom and pulling
my dick out I'd already peed on myself
and I was like I didn't even feel it oh
yeah GMC here huh but now I just look
like a nut [ __ ] scared ish a memory
skills imagine peeling like you didn't
even feel it and I was like oh [ __ ] and
then I but luckily Gaga got my back man
it [ __ ] went to the hospital the
hospital was one minute away and then
the doctor was like count backwards from
25 and I did and he's like you don't
have any brain damage like you're
slipping into a coma right now and then
you know from there once you get to a
hospital they took care of me they try
to save my foot they couldn't and then
they were like we're gonna have to
amputate it doodled in so much pain like
every time I close my eyes man it was
like the most craziest pain and then
they amputate it and then after that
it's funny because after that it just
started you started getting better and
then the shitheels of its an ascii dog
it mushy look like a chicken pot pie you
know the hard cover like yeah and look
all like slappy in shade and dude but
once I got to the hospital I'm telling
you man all over the planet thousands
and thousands of people my hospital bed
my hospital room was so cracking that I
was getting 3040 visitors a day every
day I had [ __ ] a dispensary full of
marijuana too one day the nerves of the
nurse one day the nurse opened my drawer
she got all tripped out and and I was
like what happened and she's like what
do you need to get this out of here and
I [ __ ] open the drawer and there were
like five
thousand dollars in cash like people
just kept I'm so drugged out my homies
just kept coming and dropping off cheese
like everybody [ __ ] started
like I got like 35 grand and I go fund
me and people just started flying in
from Vegas Frisco all my Pete my family
dog my my parents never left the
hospital my parents are from LA and I
was in San Bernardino my mom came
everyday almost for like six weeks and
everybody came in and so the love all
that love I had so many flowers in my
room that I had to start donating the
flowers to other rooms every day they
told me they never seen a man get so
many flowers they're like we never seen
a man get so much like so many flowers I
had all the [ __ ] doctors and nurses
bumping my music and [ __ ] like it was a
crazy expect we were making music in the
hospital room my homies are bringing a
studio equipment we were making music in
the broom my homey was giving me a legal
cable on the hospital TV issue like
trying to give me the black box because
I wanted to watch us like it was crazy
that the love was so hardcore that that
I got better faster then what dude in
London England they were making murals
for me in London and Hawaii they threw
benefits for me like nine cities and
there was so much love that I couldn't I
couldn't you know when you feel like I
cannot not make it home how could I not
okay how am I gonna [ __ ] fall off
after this dog I can't and and just you
know it was crazy man because usually
you have that kind of love is reserved
for when you die yeah and you don't
never get appreciated until you die so
in a weird way I
I almost died so I got to actually I
didn't die so I got to feel see what it
would like if you were were to die so
you called loved ya dog I swear and I
also loved before this I don't get it
twisted like even before this should
happen like I'm telling you my fans are
like my sounds like if I were to go on
Instagram be like hey I need a gallon of
milk I'd have five gallons of milk at my
door in 30 minutes hey I need a burger I
should be like you know what I should do
I should be like I'm hungry bring me a
bucket of KFC and and I'll get I'm not
joking that we get five buckets of KFC
in half an hour and then just give
people CDs and t-shirts and I'd have I'd
want three pieces of chicken not thirty
five pieces of chicken dog like we my
fanbase is so out of control
they're small but they're so loyal like
my fan base comes over and smokes
enjoying with me we watch the Dodger
game you know like hey I'm watching the
Laker game bring I got the weed you
bring the pizza and like [ __ ] there's
five food that I never met in my life in
my house now or just [ __ ] smoking you
know so I'm like oh yeah dog I have a
crazy little family but lovers it hey
for real dog week hey I should do that
KFC hustle all the time I would take
power I would take I will take the guest
list
I will take my guest is from a show like
like I'll pay dues or whatever and be
like you know these are $80 tickets so I
would be like then you know over five
days I'd be like I'm giving away a
ticket for a bucket of KFC for five days
you know like I'm some [ __ ] crazy
lawfully hey some pimp [ __ ] hey hey I do
this all on that level is all it was
always like low-budget hustles man
because I never I'm telling you I
haven't had a job since 1999 dude so her
life I see there you go dog it so I'm
talking about me - I stopped working
because I was working at Dodger Stadium
and I'll work in a security guard but
then they were like take him outside
money away to go to child support so I
working three jobs and at the end of the
week if I like half a job so are you
making that to work job done so man I
just quit after that and whatever but I
had to eat a 99 oh no no no no no I was
too working that dr. Stidham a 99 I quit
huh no no now when I met you all can
understand yes why quit like what before
I met the hair that's the last real job
that I really had it when I mean were so
fool give your social media tell us or
listeners will follow you yeah almost
the only section yeah like an Instagram
yeah
you're too mix - max OMD - mixed OMD to
NEX OMD and the numbers are very Mexican
descent yeah yeah to Mexico MD and
whatever really where you can find me in
now I probably won't check it I'm check
my Twitter alongside app Chet nah I got
a song I did I hate snapchat I hate all
that kind of stuff man Instagram a
comparison go yeah see I'm physically I
live it I was an hours from my I come
from the mice
face Friendster time doc I can only do
one social media and I press their dog
yeah coaster ride let's say I come from
the sea pixel you know I mean I can only
do
that's what Oliver and I remember I want
yeah a rush driver I know everyone I
would like you get you could build a
bunch of friends in a certain area like
San Francisco is the Mission District so
you have a hundred friends just in that
area oh but I orbit I was one of the
first Mexicans on black planet I would
like the black top the before my space
the black planet Wow the black chicks
were at so you wanted a holler the black
the black over about black planet Dave
Aude moorim [ __ ] planet
were so Philippe inspires a check on all
my dates on Filippis world.com go catch
up to mix at [ __ ] paid dues when I do
it again are at Sur September 16th and
17th there's a gala cool in my
neighborhood there wraps he's gonna be
at pay dues right miss Rama
he's from east of the river yeah yeah
yeah actually it's funny my record label
water the plants I'm an A&R for water
the plant and the first person that
signed is a girl from that crew that
cause her name is a yeah from Boyle
Heights
yeah mixed Kalon comedian miss to miss
Kelly's got a I don't talk about yeah
that I grew up with his sister in the
projects okay his is actually his mom
his mom used to be like in a crew in a
crew with a bunch of crazy chicks called
dreamers all the back in the party crude
ran across particles that she was called
the dreamers and it were sweatshirts and
they will take mad for his bro and his
father his father fired my ass my last
job bro oh it's a small world yeah man
his father and everything Mike and I'm
here to work at Adam sukizo who his
father on what miss Kelly told about his
father Mike the food ah ah he's a he's a
[ __ ] um very competitive [ __ ]
bro
that [ __ ] jump into any sports
like darts and she should be the best at
darts still play softball to a knee gave
out bro yeah like that crew that crewman
there's a boy Heights man there east of
the river there
really dope man they're really really do
I try to support all the underground
right like like reverie you talk about
reverie did man I saw reveries first
show when she would like seventeen
insecure I got here I've always been
I've always been somebody to like every
time I see like young artist in LA
underground hip-hop I always try to be
that person and give them a show you
know you're talking about like let's say
your Lopez or yeah a little water yeah
yeah I've always try to be like that man
cuz I throw month leaves and [ __ ] like
that but yeah man that's a small world
man
I just want to let people know to my new
album comes out this - yeah right there
right
oh yeah it's called launched over here
oh yeah it's called hospital he go done
and that comes out it's on I love to mix
calm and Sun iTunes and all that it
comes out Tuesday man very professional
man I am and very nice man very nice to
mix laughs spittle I love to mix calm
mmm I label water the plants I want to
give them a shout out because I taco
Nassau I'm funded by it I'm funded by a
taco shop my label do is funded by taco
nacho I became vegan right my wife Lisa
lock oh there's fish tacos hey the one
with the fish burrito bro hey Donovan ah
so is my record oil of Pomona now the
one in a the only one another one in our
industry right there one on Alondra
Bellflower Oh Baelfire all of them
they're all there anybody listening man
I will not so make the best station
talkbox was an error the shrimp Brito
the taco Nestle has the your [ __ ] they
have jalapeno peppers but you the
browning yellow one those well aware and
you bethlehem and yeah oh yeah hey
that's my label
hey water the plants they call water the
plants kako naso funds my project
holiday yeah doc so taco go to taco
nacho man they fun and they found my
showing KD I was showing a 93 5k day
oh yeah Saturday 9:00 to 2:00 in the
morning and it's called water the plan
so check your modern 93.5 KD Adam that's
thing I don't all over the world a
little coke yeah yeah all over the word
yeah yeah cuz I'm we had a guy here arm
he grew up in my neighborhood too so I
had to have him on the show um um Fabian
uh-huh he's a painter
Fabian favorite favorite favorite herb
or okay and his brother wraps his
brother has a his little brother as the
ill kids
it all pays label oh yeah Oh kids - yeah
yeah yeah almost three where sponsor me
do the yeah show his brothers Oldham
euros yeah they mail me they'd be mad
let me share so yeah we're all connected
small world here I'm telling back on
that CD is powered by taco nacho la
spittle then to be a comedian a mom
others comedian to say I was born in
Mexico in a little town called La of
spittle I did it anyways yeah he was not
that funny
where are so full also man be on the
lookout for my HBO special September 30
hell yeah go check out to mix it's gonna
be a paid juice September 16th and 17 16
and 17 okay follow his check out album
Ospital and we have we have a copy thank
you very much
I haven't bump a man bump it did you
care about me shout out for anybody uh
yeah man I want to give a shout out to a
to water the plants to talk when a so to
my boy Sully K born to a you know
everybody out there that supports the LA
underground hip-hop scene knows about me
as to mix or Mexican sent the
visionaries all my [ __ ] band
shapeshifters I got a gang of bands and
look daggers are a bunch of crew so
everybody out there representing the LA
underground project blowed and check out
this album do check on everything I love
my music is beautiful and it's worth
listening to and it's not no mumble
mouth [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
check it out
Rodrigo yeah man any shoutouts shoutouts
check out the yeah man podcast were so
full thank you for listening
picture